hi and welcome to episode number 23 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
i'm francisco and i'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark hey
Francis car you doing today very happy
very excited about the very cool
interview with with Andy yeah yeah we've
got a really nice interview today with a
gentleman from humble bundle which is a
website that I've been tracking for a
long time over the years and I'm
slightly ashamed and I really shame but
whatever actually did not know who they
were and I'm think I'm gonna start using
them soon yeah I think it's just a show
that I reply more games than you do I
think it's probably what it is i play
android games yeah yeah so that's
actually going to be our main content of
the day of the week we're going to be
talking with antioch's for uh which is
engineering manager at Humble Bundle
about how they use google cloud platform
yeah yeah it's gonna be really cool and
then after that we have our question of
the week where we're going to be talking
about Cooper needs one more time yeah
people like it but like they do they do
really like it but before we do that I
think you've got a really interesting
cool thing of the week that you managed
to find yeah so that's actually
something that i saw on twitter a couple
days ago and they thought it was really
interesting it's it's a ranking donned
by french organization that is
completely independent and i'm gonna i
gotta brag about my accent now i'm gonna
say it's a JD n which is Lou Jean Elle
unit oh very nice yeah very French and
they did a ranking about the different
different features of every single cloud
provider that we have here in the United
States and guess who came up first I
don't know maybe else yeah yeah and it
is very cool so we'll have the the
langhe on the show notes and I think
it's like yeah we are the first on the
general ranking we are the first on
every single ranking which is actually
very interesting for us too because it
kind of shows what are the things we
need to improve on yep but also issues
issues if you are trying to decide with
cloud you should go with
there's going to be a lot of different
things that you might be interested
you're going to find them in this in
this report so definitely worth having a
look yeah so I mean like if you're
looking for certain trade offs from
different cloud providers of obviously
us included it could be really
interesting read or if you're sort of
going hey I'd really like to use Google
cloud platform but I need to have
something that sort of justifies the UC
age or like helps me sort of make this
argument this sounds like a document
that might be pretty handy for you yeah
and also the the little the little
images that their creative with the
rankings they're super cute so that's
something that it's always a bonus that
definitely always helps it's right it's
very very important cool so I guess it's
time to go and talk to Andy yeah let's
talk about games we got joined today by
Andy ox felt from Humble Bundle thank
you so much for joining us today Andy
great to beer um so let's have a chat
first of all let's talk about you who
you what do you do what's your
background and stuff yes I'm an
engineering manager at humble bundle um
so I've been with a company for almost
four years I've done me a little bit of
everything worked on pretty much every
part of the code base at some point and
I originally on my background in the
gaming industry worked at Electronic
Arts for a number of years before coming
humble bundles so even though not
working on games anymore I have a lot of
familiarity and it helps a lot with you
know being our our mission has a company
being to support game developers cool so
obviously we took just a little bit
there about games um tell us what humble
bundle is like its history it's changed
a bit over the last few years but i was
i was definitely around when it first
came out and I was really excited by it
so tell us a little bit about what it is
so humble bundle was actually started by
game developers so our two founders Jeff
and John were originally working on at
Wolf I our games and they were creating
a ninja rabbit fighting game called
overgrowth them that company still
exists and they're actually doing really
awesome things there but the Humble
Bundle came out of a promotion that wolf
fire games was doing and you know they
basically wanted to create kind of the
most humble promotion hence the name
than you know what is the site you know
what would be more humble than being you
know cross-platform completely drm free
and you know letting the customer pay
whatever they want and so kind of you
know Humble Bundle kinda came a
promotion between you included
you know games from wool fire games as
well as a few other developers and you
know put them together to the first
humble bundle and you know it was so
wildly successful that you know our
founders realize you know we should try
this again and the second one was also
wildly successful and so they decided to
you know spit off into its own company
and since then you know really the
mission Humble Bundle has been to you
know support game developers and you
know create cool promotions for the
community and not only like did you
include pay what you want but also it
included like you could do donations to
charity and also do that sort of stuff
is absolutely so charity has always been
an important part of our mission and
every product we've created it has you
know some way in which we support
charity and to date we've raised more
than 70 million dollars for charity and
something we're really proud of and
something that we're going to continue
to do and you don't really take to heart
nice excellent now in the beginning I
know it was very sort of one elfish like
you sort of had these one promotions and
stuff like that though I know things are
a little bit different now do you want
to talk about like how's that different
now devices then yes you as we kind of
grew and scaled up you know we started
from you know uh bundle would come out
every few months you know we'd have
pretty long gaps where there was you
know almost nothing on our website you
know existing customers could come to it
to download the things they've purchased
but otherwise you know it's nothing to
do there and it was really a big deal i
remember the first time that we had
back-to-back bundles you know it was
like really like oh we've never tried
this before this is crazy those years
ago so now it seems kind of norm so now
we're at the point we have multiples
multiple bundles running at the same
time and we have other products who
created as well so you know now there's
always tons of things going on on our
website but yeah back when we were okay
I getting started things are definitely
a lot more kind of sparse and you know a
lot less regular than they are now so
when you're saying that you were very
successful at the beginning like every
single bundle was while success how many
people are accessing the website more or
less how we talked about in terms of
actual numbers you know I couldn't say
like numbers actually accessing but the
I do know that you know though we were
regularly seeing you up two million
purchasers for our bundles and you'll
continue to see numbers like that and
you know thinking about how you know i'm
sure many many people always visited
don't purchase so I think we're almost
definitely looking at millions of visits
but I couldn't give you the exact number
nice it's actually really cool if you go
on the website they do have the stats at
the bottom of the page what
show you like total payments split by
operating system number of purchases
I've been a long time linux user so i
used to go back on a regular basis and
be like hey linux users paying more than
windows users and stuff like that i'm
actually look at the numbers so yeah a
lot of that stuff really like exists in
like they highlight top contributors and
stuff like that it's a pretty awesome
thing you're doing thanks so you said
you were dealing with sort of like
millions and millions of millions at the
very least of people buying products
let's talk a little bit about the
technology that powers humble bundle and
what's going on there I believe you
people are using gcp mm-hmm that's
correct yeah we we've been using App
Engine since day one and you know over
time we've continued to expand our usage
of Google cloud platform offerings and
we're now using Google Cloud storage
we're using bigquery and you know
starting to use Google compute engine as
well and you know those have definitely
been critical to our success very cool
so could use a little bit more why why
did you choose that Bank in at the
beginning so we we knew that are as you
mentioned our traffic was going to be
very spiky so the you know the automatic
scaling of App Engine was absolutely
crucial for our success and you know I
don't think the company you know really
could have worked without it so the the
fact that you know so you know there's
basically you know without without
automatic scaling you know we could have
had if we had a fixed number of servers
there's two different ways that could
have gone so you could have either had
too few servers and you know customers
would have come to our website and you
know things would have a bit slower when
worked and you know customers would
available making all the purchases they
were able to make or we would have had
enough service to meet the demand but
that would mean that you know as soon as
you know really the first few hours of a
bundle have always been by far when most
of the traffic comes in but the bundle
runs for two weeks and by the end it's
more kind of a trickle purchase as
compared to the beginning so we were
paying for you know all the servers we
needed to support those initial few
hours at the end of the bundle our cost
would have been so high that there's no
way the company could have been
profitable so the fact that App Engine
you know without any thought on our part
was just able to you know scale up and
scale down as we needed we didn't even
have to think about it you know
especially you know when the company was
really small and we didn't have you know
a big team you know just allow us to get
started and just focus on you know
selling games and you know doing cool
promotions and not worrying about you
know all the old nitty gritty details of
the tech nice so knowing that humble
has been out there for quite a long time
I don't think you're using go so what
language is so we're using python that
was you know if I were to do all again I
actually might consider using go I do
like a lot of things about go but yeah
at this point I think we're pretty much
Anna have so much Python code written I
think that's what we're going to be very
nice does it'll be more about what parts
of that banking you're using that cab
engine is basically an ecosystem does
bond or things inside yep so we
definitely make extensive use of the
cloud datastore so the you know
performance and scalability the
datastore is still amazes me to this day
it's like still almost like magic to me
that they won't work so i think we weave
over time become you know I kind of
describe us as like datastore wizards
and like we know the ins and outs like
everything you can do it in like every
trick and you know how do you know
whether both from like how to you know
make you know things really fast and how
to you know keep costs down stuff like
that so that's definitely a really big
part of our platform task queues are
also really important to us so we use
task queues the most crucial thing that
goes there is our payment processing is
completely based on task queues but we
also use tasks for you know different
things like you know when we have you
know something that we want to schedule
so for example you know we often will at
like 10 a.m. every day at new products
on to our store we want to schedule it
to be at 10am we start to have someone
you know I was there and had to push a
button but now you know what task queues
we can just you know schedule an event
and we just know it's going to run
that's especially important because you
know since we were you know cell
international products sometimes you
know if sometimes and such that people
you thought to be awake at like 1am in
the morning our time zone to watch
something in another time zone but now
we just scheduled and we know it's going
to work and it just goes so you're able
to sort of leverage the ability of
tuskys to retry something fails and so
you're like I know this is going to work
at some point this is this is going to
be fine absolutely brickell that's
actually very interesting the fact that
you're using task queues for the payment
system paint like payments are a pretty
tricky thing to do could you tell me
more about how you manage that exactly
and also what are you using for for the
payments themselves yes so the real
thing we use it for is IP and handling
so so we don't actually do the direct
payment processing ourselves we use
paypal we use amazon
we stripe and ways of coinbase in a
couple others so you know we early on
you know we found that you know so if we
receive an ipn from one of them so I p n
stands for instant payment notification
and you know it's the main way in which
a company like PayPal kind of
communicates you know like it's almost
like an API they used to communicate
with us and so you know sometimes you
know if you we need the reliability of
knowing you know what an ipn comes in
that it's always going to be processed
so what we do now is what an ipn you
know when we essentially receive a
request from paypal saying hey here's a
you know here's some data we need you to
process what we do is we immediately
write an entity to the data store
contain the contents of that ipn and
then we schedule a task to process that
um and so we know that you know no
matter what goes wrong you know whether
it's sometimes you know an engineer and
our team makes a mistake and you know
there's a bug in the code and it crashes
we know that we're not going to lose
that data and you know we're gonna you
know we can look at our logs and figure
out exactly what went wrong you fix the
mistake and retry the task and you know
ultimately you know we can be guarantee
can be you know confident it's going to
be processed and that's really important
for us since you know we have really
complicated accounting since a big part
of what we actually do is you know
moving money to different places so you
know we need to make sure that our you
know developers charities customers can
trust us to make sure that you know
every penny that we receive is going to
go to the right place yeah that seems
really important especially with the pay
what you want model and the customers
can choose like which companies get what
and like what charities get what and
percentages so yeah it's not as simple
as about things 10 doubles in the things
5 and we're going to receive everything
exactly very cool so you mentioned that
using App Engine you're using data store
using task queues what else are using
from App Engine um yeah let's see we use
a memcache so I'm memcache is you know
credibly important for performance for
us since you know we want our site to
load quickly the memcache also helps us
cut down on our cost since you know
accessing the data stored directly cost
more money than using memcache we
actually recently switched to dedicated
memcache which we found actually despite
the fact that cost money in the end it
actually brought down our costs because
of the fact that it you know I think it
actually you know decreased other usages
you know fronted instance hours and
things like that to the point where it
almost certainly was
you know saves us more money that we
actually spent on it so that was
definitely a big win and you know not
only that but of course makes our site
even faster since we're able to store
more data in the cache so you're
actually using the shared the shared
memcache instance throw a long time
raising a for quite a long time and so
you'd get kicked out of that every so
often you get it you know the other
thing about the shared is that you know
over time it kind of varies how much you
have so there's times when your
performance is better but within times
when it's were so dedicated memcache
it's very predictable very very cool now
I think you also said you started using
bigquery a bit as well talk us a little
bit through what made you make that
decision and what you're doing with it
yeah so we originally started using
bigquery for our accounting system so um
you know when we used to you know every
month so we paid developers and
charities that sell through us you know
we cut them a check every month for you
however much that we owe them and then
we used to have this like complicated
map job essentially where we would go
over every order in the datastore and
then you know we realized over time that
that was not kind of scaling to our
needs and so what we now do is we you
know we leverage the automated backup
technology that app engine provides to
backup from I think it uses kind of
Google Cloud storage as an intermediary
but in the end it ends up in bigquery
and so once we have all our older data
and bigquery were able to do you know
really powerful analysis on our order
data in seconds and so we have you know
kind of complicated set of bigquery
queries that we've essentially built
over time that we kind of run put
together and you know basically now it's
fairly automated process by which you
know is now actually everyday kind of
spits out okay well here's how much
money every one that sells through years
out and we don't really have to worry
about you I used to take you know ours
now or is now second so that's kind of
been a really really great boon for us
very nice so then what you said is that
you're actually dumping the whole
datastore to cloud storage and then
uploading it back to bigquery so you can
do all you're all the queries nice yeah
and so we also in addition to that we
also have been taking advantage of
streaming and bigquery so we also stream
our data as well and we we like to use
both because you know we can kind of
check for discrepancies and just you
know just be a hundred percent confident
that you know every order
representative bigquery that's pretty
cool so basically you've taken advantage
of sort of two of our big managed like
services so I'm guessing you still don't
have much of an ops team and the company
usually have no ops team at all week
nicely they're able to rely on you know
the cloud platform and again that's you
know wonderful because just to be honest
none of us want to do ops yeah not what
our backgrounds in and so yeah you know
let's just focus on writing code there's
a very good fun so what what else do you
use for so you mentioned cloud storage
use it for a temporary backup for data
store these it for something out like
your images or some binaries or whatever
yep so we use it our other big thing is
serving images as you mentioned so we've
actually you know built started building
a suite of internal tools around it that
allows okay so we have a team internally
that you know kind of make sure you know
all the image assets for the various
promotions we put together and the right
place so they'll upload all the assets
into Google Cloud storage and so
essentially you know what we're
engineering team is built is essentially
a kind of like a legacy amassing a
content management system for putting
bundles together that another team in
our company uses to actually put the
bundles together and so Google Cloud
storage you know allows us to do this
because you know when we were kind of
tiny and when their engineers used to
build every bundle by hand that meant
that you know every time we wanted to
change what bundles active you know we
had to deploy the site but now that you
know we're able to use Google Cloud
storage host the images we can just
upload the images to cloud storage
reference the images from the live site
and not have to like to play so that's
been a really big win for us as well
very cool so since you mentioned
deploying how often do you deploy
probably like 10 times a day so nice
more Wow well I that actually code
deployment so it just changes the
database or both code deployments how
many how many modules that you have
which is like one big module so we have
almost like Pride ninety-five percent
error code bases in one module and we
have a few other kind of tiny your
modules the kind of the other the most
notable ones so we've we've built a
uploader which uses sore CDN which is a
separate company does that so we've
built an uploader that the uploader does
run an app engine and so that is
per module that it's guy have a very
isolated problem we wanted to solve and
select able to live separately and use
different technologies which is nice do
you store the binaries for the games or
is that help done by third-party let's
know so we do store the binaries and
that's what the CDN does and that's what
this kind of uploader module does is
uploads the bynars to our CDN so I'm
curious like what would you consider
probably the biggest challenge you've
encountered when building Humble Bundle
working with Google cloud platform
what's been sort of the trickiest
problem that you've come across yeah
definitely scalability although app
engines tools definitely provide
solutions to that you know we've it
comes down to you know often will write
our code have you no problem once always
just get the code working and so for
example when we built the humble store
which is a bit of a more traditional
storefront that unlike our bundles which
are pay what you want the humble store
is fixed price sales we first built that
we got to put it together in just a
couple weeks then you know the time we
only had 10 games on it so the original
solution we built for it was not
scalable at all we were actually dumping
you know the entire inventory directly
to the browser so you know I first
loaded pretty fast and you know we hit
50 games will starting be a little
slower once we had a hundred games on
the store you know the store was taking
about 10 seconds to load and we realize
you know we're going to have to use a
better approach and so you know I looked
up the technologies happened she
provided and we were able to leverage
task queues and memcache and you build a
more sophisticated system that now we
kind of you know do it you know much
smarter approach where we only send you
know kind of the games that the browser
needs to know about and so you know now
we have thousands and thousands of games
on our store and you know the store
loads very fast cool and something that
our customers very often wonder is how
do you monitor all these system mm-hmm
so yeah we have a number of ways we do
that so we have a bunch of things we've
kind of built internally on top of the
log system in App Engine so we have you
know cron jobs that you know run you
know every few minutes that check the
logs for you know look for exceptions
and stuff like that if they're above a
certain threshold they'll actually like
pinger phones occasional in the middle
of the night
you know lets us know when things go
wrong and we also have you know kind of
dashboards that we look at you know some
of those we build by hand I actually
check our App Engine usage every day
just you know make sure if our numbers
are going to hide you have you know in
case you know engineer accidentally
deployed some code that you know doing
tons and tons of data store reads that
we don't want that way we catch it
before our bill ends up going too high
more recently we've been starting to
look into some of the new stackdriver
things so we're just kind of starting to
wrap our heads around that and see how
we can take advantage of that but we've
already we set up if you kind of custom
metrics and we're fine looking at the
dashboards there and starting to see
it's definitely really exciting
technology and we're just starting to
figure out how we can use it cool yeah
what's the only thing about a stack
driver when you said it's like yeah he
thinks me in the middle of the night we
can do that as a service midnight
wake-up call yes good call so could you
mention you already talked about what
were the the hardest things what about
the best thing like what is the moment
where you said wow it's cool to be
running on the cloud yeah so I mean
there's definitely a number of those I
mean it's really cool when you know when
we launch a bundle and you just you know
as you mentioned you know there's a live
counter of you know how many people are
okay purchasing at the bottom then you
know just seeing like all these people
coming in and you know not and thinking
about just how many requests are being
handled and the fact that we didn't have
to worry about that you know just an
amazing thing you know it's also you
know really satisfying you know when
we've done some some cool optimization
tasks we've done that have you know
found ways of you know making our site
faster you know it's really cool when
you know when you know sometimes we've
had pages that you know are taking a
little longer to load and we've realized
oh hey if we use the data store in this
different way or if we add some memcache
on top of this and we get it down to
like 100 milliseconds so those are been
cool very nice I have a question ladies
like super technical but I'm very
curious about how you're doing this so
I'm looking at the Humble Bundle web
page right now and I can see the bundle
sold and it's noticed that it changes so
are you are you using WebSockets
WebSockets with App Engine how a mess
that work so we're actually using popped
up for that so
a startup called pub nub that
essentially provides like a kind of pub
sub style thing where you can basically
push notifications from the server side
to the browser and that their technology
makes it really easy to do oh yeah very
interesting because I know that we have
some some there's the web's that is that
I think a pension socket 80s channels
and that I have not used that much but I
was very curious about it yeah we
haven't actually looked too much into
that either but that does I do think it
was probably pretty similar to the
service patna provides I wasn't between
that of firebase oh yeah yeah excellent
I'm cool is there anything we haven't
talked about but you'd like to highlight
or you think is particularly interesting
about what's going on behind the scenes
at humble bundle mm-hmm well one thing I
do want to highlight is that we are
hiring software so you know our website
is job humble bundle calm and we
definitely encourage anyone interested
to check it out you know having
experienced a google cloud platform is
definitely a big plus for us so yeah
yeah if anyone ends up blind to Humble
Bundle because of these podcast I could
love to know yeah yeah definitely cuz I
think that maybe they have referral
bonus or something maybe I don't leave
it I think the other big question is a
you a pc or console gamer i'm a pc
gamers so um starcraft 2 is you know for
many years with my weapon of choice and
a masters league so yeah where you know
we definitely ought humble bundle of a
mix we have some hardcore PC gamers okay
some hardcore console gamers so I'm
definitely a pc gamer cool I think we
should go visit them at their office one
day I think you guys are welcome
absolutely any day go well thanks so
much for taking the time to come by the
office and talk to us today absolutely
great to be here thanks for having me
thanks so much cool so thanks again to
Andy for such an interesting
conversation I really learned a lot
about how they use the Google cloud
platform but also I learned a lot about
cool things like they actually are very
active on Terry ya know humble bundle is
a really interesting product um just for
business perspective nothing else yet as
well as sort of the stuff they've been
doing for selling games in indie games
and also the good stuff it's a project
I've tracked for a really long time yeah
I'm not sure buying more games
it's a very good idea for me right now
because you can never have enough games
yeah they'll have enough time here so I
don't know there's a trade-off to be
done in there absolutely go so let's go
with a question of the week which is as
we said before about Cooper Nettie's and
it came through Google+ from one of our
previous interviewees yes and very
active commenter very very active high
heron well you're hearing yeah you're
listening to us so here in sent us a
really cool question one that I've
definitely had before a discussion
around the fact that crib annuities 1.2
doesn't have any idea of chron so if you
want to say set up a scheduled task that
does something on a regular basis say
everyone's a day I want to know
something like that community doesn't
have anything built in so how do you end
up doing that yeah so I I guess that
it's important to mention that it's not
perfect or entities as one or two but
it's planned to be released with 103 yes
so so yeah what what do you do then so I
think you have a couple of options there
um one of maybe maybe the most basic
ones is you can set up a cron just like
unlike a GC instance one of the nodes on
g own crew benetti's just using standard
Linux krun you know running the commands
and doing that stuff and to set up a set
up a job now actually I'll backtrack for
a minute and say greenies does have a
concept of jobs so if you have a one-off
task or one-off process you want to run
have it be managed by communities make
sure it gets finished that sort of stuff
jobs are definitely the thing you need
to look at but what you want to do is
you'd want to fire off that job on a
regular basis yeah yeah so jobs i'd say
jobs is more like things like mapreduce
and stuff it up where you have like
these are these needs to be processed at
some point just yes yeah exactly yeah
but so so you're saying that basically
you could start one of those jobs
through cold on from an instance of GC
instance yep running chrome running cron
that would work that would be okay but
there's actually nothing stopping you
from using the Crone ability within that
engine I actually like that much better
I like this much better too obviously
then it's a managed service you
absolutely know like it's never gonna
let go down like if that GC instance
I'd in a bowling fire and that would be
bad and you may not know you need
monitoring but you know Cuban ADIZ has
an API so you can set it up so that you
know you can fire off a job using the
API from App Engine and then you can
probably feel a whole lot happier about
it that it's happening and it's always
going to happen at the time it's meant
to happen I think that's my favorite
yeah also the thing that I like about
this solution is that it's so Quran on
app engine is based on task queues which
means that if for any reason the request
that you're sending fails it will be
retried yeah so it's also a bonus you're
basically just winning there and I think
it even comes with exponential back-off
and all those really fancy things if you
need to so it's very easy to set up and
it's very reliable yeah no absolutely so
I think that's a that's definitely the
way I go especially you know obviously
you're running on Google cloud platform
I think that's an easy solution and you
know with the scale 20 of the standard
app engine you're not paying for very
much either yep cool well before we
finish with this amazing episode why
don't you tell us a little bit about
what you're gonna be doing something so
discuss it in last episode as well but i
will be in kentucky as an end of naath
next week i will be seeing vector conf
talking about games in the cloud doing a
little round table and i think that when
you say next week is this week because
it is this week it is this way it is
this area right yeah yeah we're
recording for once we actually recording
with days in advance yes sir this week I
will be in Kentucky it'll be a vector
conf talking about games in the cloud
and then after that I will be at the
Louisville GDG talking about communities
I know you're going on a little travel
as well yeah I'm gonna be in Budapest
Hungary it's going to be pretty awesome
it's going to be for crafts comp and I'm
going to be running a go-go workshop at
the craft gump there's going to be many
other people very cool people like
Kelsey Hightower he's going to be doing
a cooper nineties workshop I know that I
fear he's going to be there talking
about the sewerage systems Jesse
frizzell is gonna be there time
yeah sounds like a lot of really fun
people that I want to hang out with and
learn from so that's gonna be very fun
and I believe it also went live recently
you're going to be speaking at Google
i/o gaddafi speaking I oh yeah pretty
excited about that more work so yeah
google i/o it's uh it's gonna be month
of you this year yeah it's gonna be from
May eighteenth to me 20th yeah and yeah
i'm gonna be talking about cloud spin
excellent i'll be there as well i'll be
talking about multiplayer games using
firebase yeah so and will actually be
somewhere hanging out around there so
we'll give you more details on exactly
how this is going to work but if you're
planning on attending google i/o let us
know yeah say hi would love to say hi
cool well thank you again mark for Jenny
me this week and thank you all the
listeners for joining us absolutely
great to have everyone and don't forget
you know you want to send us questions
of the week or things that are cool
please do so we love to hear from you
all awesome talk to the next week see
you next week
you